absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
I would have laid well today I'm lucky
enough to be joined by a true icon of
New Zealand Rugby from the late 90s he
was a crowd favorite every time he ran
out at the old carersbrook stadium while
playing for either otago or the
Highlanders he then moved over to
Scotland to play International Rugby
basically within a week of moving there
and the best thing about today's guest
is that everyone I've spoken to has
described him as one of the best Lads
you'll ever meet so I'm stoked to have
him on he is of course Brendan chainsaw
Laney welcome mate what an intro what an
intro is it chainsaw most people call
you chainsaw still or is it moved on to
Buffalo yeah
um and it was just a bad haircut at
school was that yeah yeah and that sort
of stuck around other people probably
say it's something else bit of a dumb
bastard but
um you know Buffer's probably the what
everyone sort of pretty close to me
calls me and what about we had a
chainsaw come about is that just a more
of a rugby thing yeah it really was it
was sort of uh it was 98 all sort of
kicked off in Reuben Parkinson's got a
lot to chance for he was the one that
sort of got to get got a big gun down in
Dunedin because it at the time remember
Paul Cook he played on the left wing for
a hundred games scored Legend absolute
Legend and uh terrific guy just a
champion guy and uh was very good after
dark as well
Manny could score some tries but he used
to run down the saw line when he scored
a try and and shoot people oh yeah I can
shoot a Stevenson yeah and no one no one
really did anything like that when we
were down there and the cookie was the
last guy you see and um and Rubes sort
of thought well why don't we get it
started again and he sort of said to me
one day and we were mucking around he
said to me one day he said well I won't
use you know Austin like a log and you
took me down like a chainsaw or
something yeah jokingly
and nothing nothing was done because it
was at the start of the year yeah
nothing was done we were no one even
played up but right through the year it
was about halfway through the year there
was mural elections on
in around the side of the ground was
signs
um Chainsaw for mayor and Suki Familia
and all these other guys for me and and
there was this chainsaw one and you
hadn't done that celebrations no no or
just it just come out of nowhere and I
thought it was they were talking about
Goldie oh hey did we played a midweek
game it was by plenty of something
and it was on the sword and I'm even
saying the roots I said see they've got
a sworn about Goldie and he was like I
don't think it's gold
and uh and it was me so um we went to
the pub that night
and we're in the in the uh I think it
was the Oriental still wanted me in the
fat lady's arms in and uh two dollar
drunks oh man I couldn't go couldn't go
past that so we hooked into a few and
there was a quite a few of the scarfies
in the corner and one of them walked
past me and I knocked his arm and pumped
his drink out of his hand two bucks
I can replace it real quick so I said
well look I'm really sorry and he said
oh no worries chainsaw and carried on
walking and Reuben heard this and he
would see you told you and that's how it
stuck and then got towards this sort of
I think it was or the last game of the
round or semi-final or something rude
said mate if you score a Troy you've got
to do something yeah and I said oh what
do I do I think I looked like this
stupid and of course I did so I did it
scored a Troy pretended to start a
chainsaw and yeah stuck like yeah
proverbial to a blanket so and if I'm
honest mode if someone stuck one in
front of me now I wouldn't know what to
do so it's been uh it's been a weird
ride I must admit you know well with me
my wife and I have gone into a
restaurant to have dinner or something
and there'll be someone from the other
side of the room a chainsaw egg and of
course
wave into someone and you don't know who
they are and but it's been cool look
it's it's been fun like people you know
they've certainly still remember it yeah
um but the you know the older yet and
the more gray hairs will get the yeah so
it seems a hell lot better it's probably
more a hex or near do we say
um yeah it's been a weird ride mate how
many times did you actually do the
chainsaw celebration was it just twice a
year
oh I think it was my last game what did
it last game we played here in
Christchurch I played the final
and we scored a try under the post and
we actually got in front no getting beat
boy Kingery but
um and I did it then and there was
probably about the last time we've did
because when we went to Scotland because
they didn't really know much about it
yeah until somebody tuned up with the
chain sort of
Scottish thing it tuned up to a press
conference with this bloody chainsaw can
you stand on a come outside it's in on a
tree stump and well one of the just the
media guys
[Laughter]
so yeah now it's funny it's it's um it's
been really cool but um yeah it's
certainly yeah it's it's probably worn
its name here
well one thing I do like to do on this
um podcast is go through the Journey
from the start so I'm always Keen to
hear how it was like for you growing up
so understand your deep deep south
deeper than I first originally thought
yeah mate yeah obviously uh lived in
Bluff
um right down to about just just before
two and five oh dear there's a policeman
down there oh yeah so uh mum did uh
decided that when I got to about four or
five you've got to transfer to tamuka so
we really went up the tree and uh and I
went so um I first started going to
school in temuka oh yeah five years old
so I we lived across the road
um from oh sort of right side police
station across the road from soccer
um fuel yeah Canyon square is cool in
the middle of smokes so away for the
first sort of five six months said on
the on the um
nuts to get across the road and play
football yeah and I ended up going over
there they all been stuck a pair of
boots from me and sent me across the
road and I played soccer till I was
about 10. oh was it at 10 yeah so um was
until um in the course of Rugby Club it
was right behind the police station yeah
and Dave got involved with rope Club
down there and so I ended up going down
there with one day when I was about nine
and he said how are you despite
everything you know I was hanging around
with a couple of mates cutting the line
and mixed when I was playing rugby so I
got home and the old man got a massive
tune-up because he said the old lady
went right off the deep end oh my boy's
not playing rugby yeah yeah and um and
yeah well he's up flag and soccer and
and playing playing I spent most of my
time outside anyway
to come to me were you good at soccer oh
I can't enjoyed it Striker yeah it
wasn't it wasn't missive on uh defending
it's pretty Keen to score a score of
goals so I spent most of my time down
the end leaning on the goal post to the
ball come down so yeah it was are
probably the best gamer uh for a kid to
start yeah playing yeah and then you
know I was busy with me I ended up you
know goalkeeping and all the Aries to it
and yeah and but Tomoka was so many
other sports to play as well it wasn't
just football there was all always
something to go and do so it was quite
cool and how did you go when you first
gave rugby a crack did you love it from
the start yeah it was supposed to it's
like in this small town you played
everything yeah you know you go to
school you were bull rushed there was
cricket there was rugby there was soccer
there was yeah and and it was the same
kids playing those Sports and all and
all the you know small towns and and
temuka was no different so
um yeah rugby I was playing at school
anyway so I'd play soccer on Saturday
and rugby for the school oh yeah so um
to change over probably wasn't too much
for major really I just got chucked on
the wing and ripped into it so it was
cool and when did you think it was
potentially something you wanted to do
long term well I I actually I boxed for
about boxer yeah always be at 12 and I
did 12 13 14 and then I started getting
to that point with boxing where it was
either boxing or rugby oh yeah and and I
couldn't do both you go and play game I
got called out one day I played rugby in
the morning and we went up to feel he
played rugby and I was meant to box at
night and if I got ninja I would have
had to call Ford off because you know I
find it guys to fight around the country
wasn't that easy yeah so um my boxing
trainer found out uni woods and he gave
me a dressing down
to the boxing fight that night and he
said you could have made a choice so we
ended up poking rugby yeah you know
getting punched in the head wasn't a
great great idea really so um so yes I
chose rugby were you good at boxing day
oh my gosh I made um
I've got the gold gloves yeah it was
gone gloves
um uncontested yeah no one else tuned up
um I got food in New Zealand and New
Zealand Champs one year I think there's
only about 62 kgs or something different
but um
and uh what age grade was that uh so I
was around about 14. oh yeah yeah so it
wasn't really that heavy to be fear but
yeah um things have changed obviously
but um but yeah that was cool I love the
boxing part it was the training I was
probably the furthest I've ever been
yeah and uh so I do that train rugby you
know and we did a lot of training for
boxing yeah uh heap of training so um
you know I was probably like I said I
was the philliest first I've ever been
and it was just an enjoyable Sport and
at amateur level
you're not really getting smacked around
too much yeah you know they're pretty it
was pretty safe you know you get one in
the smaller they pull it up pretty quick
and I got the fish here he's raising up
here so have you ever been tempted to
get back in the ring or I've done it
once was that a lot like Fight For Life
types it was you it was down in
invercargill was fought for kids
um there were fundraising down here in
the South for
um the Children's Hospital in jury
Windows
um rang me up one day and see door
and I don't want to do it because you're
my mate so anyway or about two weeks
later there's another guy perhapsible
who played for Southland and he I owed
him a favor and he rang me up and he
said you're doing it and I was like [__]
so I trained for about they trained for
about three months 12 weeks yeah yeah I
trained for about seven and um because I
was really late to the police and I
wasn't the fittest man in the world and
Jerry had lost 14 kgs and he came out I
didn't realize how big the event was it
was 3 000 people at the stadium and I
was the main fight against Jeremy and he
came out with this guy this kid that was
with pitch black yeah and he comes out
with this kid holding the Swede
wonders who played for Seattle for years
yeah he's like he's 80d and uh he's
bouncing around anyway and uh I was
thinking what the hell have I got myself
in for
eign
uh yeah last last part for me you
wouldn't do it again
now I got asked to do that um before no
way yeah
yeah so then you chose rugby and then
from there what was what was your sort
of pathway well it was sort of um it
wasn't all well let's say it wasn't what
temuka high school wasn't a big school
for for rugby
um so I sort of went into Timaru boys
high yeah um I played all my Rugby for
temuka at the club
great Club had a fantastic time I was
very lucky they they were they were a
real good club to be involved in one of
the bigger clubs around South Canterbury
so um and I went in school to Timaru
boys and and uh there was two guys there
that uh or one client particular guy
Grant McFarland was my first 15 coach
but he was actually started off being my
form teacher oh yeah and Mecca was a he
had is a champion guy and uh he said I
want you to come in and play fish for a
third rugby and I was playing for temuka
under 18s at the time yeah so he said um
we want you to come to town I was like
oh [__] what do I do it or not
so I thought well Burger I'm gonna go
and give it a go and it's it was the
best thing I ever did I went and played
fish for thin rugby attorney boys been
you know made the South Island secondary
schools and yeah it was just a cool cool
drawing best rugby I'll probably ever
played on sure if this was the thing was
most enjoyable yeah it was yeah it was
you know you got the their real trouble
feeling around the hackers the modules
wouldn't have a lot of some answers
um but we were we had a really good side
that year and uh we won 40 over uh five
um games there in the schools sure I
think we scored something like a
thousand points in their Club season oh
yeah and um and scored about well some
ridiculous minute Choice something like
160 odd choice so we we were
a pretty handy team but then there's no
despicable the things we're applying but
we just seem to be going pretty bloody
well yeah what position were you what
was on the wing oh yeah yeah it's pretty
purely on the right wing scoring tries
for fun yeah it was below that I was
getting about four or five a game which
was crazy
um sometimes I didn't have to do a lot
yeah but there was just the way that um
Grant McFarland and the guy Kevin Glover
Kevin we ended up coaching South
Canterbury and the Honda Civic um but
that's the way they played the love to
play the game yeah so we threw it around
from everywhere under our own sticks we
hardly kicked yeah
um but was yeah just cool fun yeah and
did you make New Zealand schools or
anything I didn't no no I didn't make
New Zealand schools that year
um and South Island surgery schools as
well as high as I got school-wise yeah
and then I came back and um and went
straight back to my club for temuka so
um it's been my first years out of
school which was 92. sitting on the
bench I think I played about three
senior games that you really I sit and
watched pretty much the whole year which
was frustrating as hell but I learned a
lot yeah and um it made me uh it made me
you know pretty hungry yeah but also
maybe
um I appreciate the fact that I you know
when I dig it in there I had to play
bloody well stay there yeah was your
ambition to be uh footy player back then
um to be feared no it probably wasn't in
a way I just I just love being involved
in the game yeah and and the club and
and it was just a it wasn't especially
in a small town temuka in fact you know
the game on Saturday was such a big
thing
um and and I think you know any guy
who's played in a small town it became a
real Vocal Point the Rugby Club was big
you know everyone went and watched and
it was just a big big day Saturday
and uh you know I'd go down and referee
rugby juniors in the morning I'd go and
watch my sister play netball in the
afternoon over the netball court so I
spend most of my day or pretty much the
whole day down at down at Road Club yeah
and he would stay have a couple beers
they all been a couple of jugs and where
we go home so there was a that was the
way it was in a small town yeah it's
crazy that it was so hard for you to get
a get a run for your club team yeah yeah
Schoolboy talent coming out well and
there was a bit like that I think it was
a Schoolboy Luna yeah Stripes
um
yeah and most of our team were you know
a lot older they were sort of that 26 27
28 yeah and all of them Moonlight age
group so you know it wasn't it wasn't as
if there was I was the youngest boy
quarter but yeah it was quite a bizarre
bizarre feeling they look after you have
authorities and initiation yeah I still
didn't had to do them yeah I still had
to do them
um I was never good at drinking a jug in
a hurry but
I moved here pretty quick yeah yeah I
probably I was probably more the guy
that stayed all night but yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
didn't drink it in a hurry
so um but you know we were I suppose I
was really lucky in that
professional rugby happened a bit later
and I got I got that sort of emitter
rugby and and I think it was some of the
best rugby um not I didn't enjoy the
professional stuff but I've got a really
good mix of it yeah and so then you did
eventually start playing for South
Canterbury how did that sort of come
about yeah well I actually played for
South Canterbury when I was still at
school I did yeah yeah I um yeah I
hadn't been in the senior team yet and
Kevin Drogo was coaching South
Canterbury at the time as well and we
played against my first game was against
the New Zealand Colts
yeah and it was it was the year 91 when
John Hart had them yeah teen was awesome
well I think I marked Damien Kelly yeah
I think the only time I touched him was
after the game on the shook hands
it's called two fantastic tries that day
I've never tried to tackle him I think
I'll hit him with my head and let myself
out that was yeah I mean we're going and
played on yeah
gone but um and then I played the next
day in the first 15 game there you go oh
far out none of this uh yeah it was
Splash on the face and into it again so
yeah but they hit her they had an
outstanding team that New Zealand Corps
team that year and then they went on a
bit Aussie boy 60 70 points wow yeah
Mark Ellis Lee Stevenson they had an
awesome team I was packing myself
so you were at school so you were at 17
yeah yeah 17 18. all right and then you
play how many games do you end up
playing and about 45 I think it was at
the end yeah and then I saw I finished
and my fish came with 1990
um and 91 sorry and then I finished in
94 and went down to Dunedin what what
inspired the move how did you end up
down there I went my dad's sort of
families Dunedin anyway hi my
grandmother lived there my uncles all
lived there but I went on a sevens trip
with otago with Arthur Stone
and we were into Sri Lanka
yeah and we went and he was the coach
yeah which was a loose word yeah Stoney
was an absolute Champion man
um but he enjoyed the nightlife too and
the service trip was uh was Bloody great
we had a lot of fun but um and and we
were playing against
um you know there was some really weak
oppositions probably not the best word
but there were certainly you know a lot
of Asian companies countries and yeah we
had such a good time we had a pool but
while I was over there he said do you
want to come to Dunedin come and play
for kaikourai and
um by the end of the trip I said well
I'll come in and say good day and have a
look around and I went down there with
my dad and we sat down there at the pub
at the normanby tavern and had a beer
and going up the club rooms played a bit
of touch set night on the Wednesday and
had a good look around and and by the
end of it Dad said well what do you want
to do I said yeah I'll come give it a
crack it goes well worst case scenario
if you don't like it you get in the car
and you come home yeah so I did yeah I
never looked back so there's no promises
from my target or anything like that
nothing just purely just Club footage no
um it was just uh go down and play for
um play for cockroy yeah
um I did have a meeting my I wouldn't
have stayed with my uncle
um
and Michael was the head of traffic
officers then he was a chief Danny and
um so he worked in the same offices
called he Hunter oh yeah so he actually
um I got down there on the Sunday night
and he said uh Monday morning have a
steak you got to be in South Dunedin
police station
and meet Gordon Hunter I went sorry you
guys get your ass down there I said mate
what are you doing there for I said my
mom just here to you know play Club
rugby just get down there yeah so I had
a meeting with goody and he walked in
the office
I don't remember he had a big wall
Planner on the on the wall but it had
positions yeah
and I was packing myself because I first
started it was called Thunder
in one eye I don't know where to look
and he walked in and he didn't didn't
say a lot yeah he said about five years
to me and uh and I was crapping myself
yeah and he and and he heads um you know
first seconds and I was down as Center
because I played for the New Zealand
cult set you at Center
and he had Mark Ellis full Gordon Jason
Wright a gap of about three in me oh
yeah and that's how far down I was yeah
and he said well if you want to be up
there LED you've got to work hard
went home and uh and that was that was
the meeting I had with Courtney Hunter
so I knew where I stood and and you know
there was some pretty handy footballers
around the target at the time but I
didn't go down there for that at all
yeah just came down for for a bit of a
life change and
and that just happened to be part of the
part of the part of the gig you must
have worked hard
yeah it was sort of supposed to like
anything you go down there and and uh
you sort of want to prove yourself and I
did
um I was from a small town but it was
all
Bright Lights big city for me you know I
was going down there and I was making
all a lot of new people and it was a
pretty pretty cool experience but it was
sort of going to Varsity but not going
to Varsity in a way yeah I went to all
the parties had a great time doing that
but it was it was just a cool Town yeah
and you know bigger than to Mercury
obviously
um and just everything was happening in
the in the rugby scene down there was
great I suppose like anybody you know
going to a bigger city yeah it was just
cool and the guys have met at the club
were great people and um and I got
involved with uh tiger sevens first
and then um interplayed with a tiger B I
got I I reserved in 95 for otago um for
the semi-final and stuff so I was sort
of in and about it but it wasn't fully
in the site yeah
and then uh and then of course markelle
stuck way to league and
there's a few bristles left at the year
yeah and so I got a bit of a chance next
year so so you weren't studying down
there what were we doing to survive it
was
which I think everyone's going to give
it a crack yeah and uh you know see what
it's like on the other side and uh so I
did that for about oh probably 18 months
I suppose all day chefs yeah I was doing
full day shifts and um and they hit her
at least they have a breakfast on for
two bucks all you can eat honestly
they'll be knocking at the door open up
get them all in there and then they come
in and they get their Pokey money and
then going to the pokies they'll be
drinking booze at eight o'clock in the
morning it was unbelievable yeah
so when you cracked otago was that first
when Mark Ellison stuff had left is this
when you got your first was it contract
was it professional there no no it
wasn't
um 95 it wasn't professional
um 96 it sort of started
did why
um and I was sort of right on the on the
cusp of being involved and not been
involved in that 95 year and like I said
when Mecca headed away uh feel good and
hit it away as well so I sort of got a
wee bit of a sniff
and um and was loving every minute of it
yeah um I played about four games that
fusio went down to Dunedin and um a
couple midweek games got my first cap
and and I was singing sometimes what the
hell am I doing here you know because it
was all bigger faster you know you're
playing against guys you've seen on TV
yeah and I was thinking you know I'm
from you know to mooka what the hell am
I doing here so it was a bit of a change
but once again I was Keen to prove
myself and and the next year I sort of
got into their target team and and
strung a few performers together I think
what happened too was Greg Cooper as he
made a bit of a comeback
and um in 96 when he played a couple of
games and he pulled his groin so I was
actually reserved fullback oh yeah and
he when he heard his groin he was out
pretty much first year so probably one
of the reasons I got in there was was
coops was out yeah well it probably was
just just a chance and um so I grabbed
it and ran with it so how good and what
was that amateur scene like obviously
you weren't both sort of eras what was
it like back then like awesome yeah
only the enjoyment part was was probably
the bit that was you know you still had
to play you know really important rugby
you played bloody hard you got stuck in
in you know you were playing first
division rugby yeah but there was that
enjoyment part to it because it was
still you know amateur yeah and and you
were playing for pride you know you're
playing to
for the for the you know logo on your
left tip yeah and that was what it was
really important
um and but then there was the enjoyment
afterwards yeah you know we and otago
was exactly like any other you know
Province they enjoyed a beer afterwards
probably more than we should have and um
but we enjoyed it as a team and in that
environment was really bloody good and
and that's why otago was probably
well I loved it anyway you know a lot of
guys that went near State yeah
um and you know you're John tomuzio
Aaron Pina is that they set the scene
really in those early 90s and and I was
lucky enough to to sneak on the end of
that and carry on yeah was there an
instant change when it went professional
or no no there was an issue it probably
what what purely for my view it was one
of those ones where they changed to
professional rugby it became right you
you're in here at nine o'clock on 18 in
the morning you don't leave till five at
night we were doing that five days a
week you're training three times a day
and it actually got the point where they
realized [__] we can't do that yeah we
can't do that to people's bodies we
can't do it mentally and and and we were
bashing the hell out of each other too
you know you'd go to training and I was
a professional tickleback here for a
while
um so you know it it took us you know I
think it probably took New Zealand Rugby
about four or five years to figure out
what professional rugby looked like and
try and here they all looked
um so I think by the time what I sort of
left
um to go overseas I think New Zealand
Rugby actually figured out that
you know proficiently
um we had to do it differently yeah than
they have that's interesting yeah it's
interesting that they went that hard
there yeah oh I wish them well man we
used to not absolute [__] of each other
and you know a lot to our trainings and
five days away yeah five days a week it
was crazy you get the um Friday you'd
ever took captains running you'd be
absolutely naked you know you couldn't
get through it but it was just the way
that we thought we had to do it yeah
um but things changed pretty quickly you
know the guys you know I suppose they
listen to the guys and there was some
big big Personalities in there as well
yeah you know I know a lot of guys like
you know Brownie and Goldie and it and
tane
you know they they had uh they listened
to them which was fantastic because we
wouldn't have survived Karen
but it was the sort of Glory Days of
otago back then as well I remember
Harrisburg was always seemed to be fully
packed yeah you had a lot of success in
your time as well so yeah we were lucky
we were probably lucky you'll obviously
I sort of tacked on the end of that
professional
uh that's why the early 1990s with the
way that the tiger played and they got a
lot of people into the ground because of
the way they played you know they threw
the ball around from anywhere the school
tries from anywhere
um and Karen's book was a special place
um it was hard to it's hard to explain
to people who have never been there and
and you'd sort of run out before a game
you just get this wave off the off the
embankment and it just was a cool place
to play and the scarf he's got involved
and and you know it's it was Bloody cool
yeah it's really cool and and you know
now they've got that Stadium down there
and I'd love to be now to play it yeah
oh imagine the chainsaw down the wing
downstairs
yeah it's just on topic but karisbrook
just there was just something special
about it yeah it was a cool place and I
suppose to you know going back to a city
earlier it was about you know playing
for the promises a real pride in playing
for otago regardless of whether you came
from the province because like like I
said a lot of guys came down from Boston
yeah but they stayed you know they
became Dunedin became home for them and
uh and and but it was the way that the
tiger were playing you know we didn't
know I suppose there was times where we
didn't win a lot either but we went out
there and threw everything at it you
know yeah and you mentioned a few of
those players that you played with any
one of them really stand out as just
someone who just loved playing with oh
look to be fear if if you were gonna
pick an individual I was once again
really lucky I think the year 98 when we
won things here uh won the UBC there was
nine guys in the All Blacks all right
you know that was unbelievable there was
the car yard out the front looked like a
Ford carrier
Kelvin minutes in the Night Live
Together we'd pull up in his Mitsubishi
look bloody stupid but
um you know like there was some
fantastic players you know Tain that was
um Crusher our full pack with only two
guys in the in the middle row with um
John Blake and Brendan timsey who didn't
make the All Blacks so you know the
front row was was awesome yeah um you
know he had into on Oliver Carl hofst
and case Muse
but if you were going to pick a guy just
purely individually who's you'd have to
pick defaults he was just he was an
outstanding athlete not just rugby
player because he could play cricket he
was a bit of a sport ability to do
anything he used to hate playing Cricket
again you know when you're yeah on your
way on tour and you get in and you want
to be down the hallway plan he'd turn up
near the Earth screw this way out of
here he'd either get you out with battle
Dave I'm not parked I don't see you
later I'm out of here yeah and he used
to get shitty if he got out and all that
sort of stuff as well but he was scared
of it but he was that good you know but
he was like that as uh I used to love
playing with Goldie because of the way
you sort of knew what he could do
but he was an outstanding
um guy putting in space and you could
rely on it fullback he was outstanding
out of the high ball but man what a
guide to having your team so we're once
again pretty lucky and he was one of a
few but you'd have to say he was he was
the one and what about that front row
they seem like an intimidating Bunch
yeah
well when you know like Carl host he
came down from uh um I mean when he
first turned up I was like all the sides
of this burger yeah the biggest one was
case Muse I mean when case tuned up he'd
come from Auckland mate he was a monster
wow this was this guy
um and and you know he'd had a few
issues with his calves and and he'd had
to have operations and stuff from his
Achilles and yeah so he he'd come down
started but he sort of had a few
problems
and then that next year 97 and eight man
he was awesome yeah he really was so
that's when he made the allex obviously
and uh and then we had yeah antonova
well hatch was the quintessential front
row tough strong fast and and didn't
take prisoners
um but in in once again we had those
three guys together yeah
um made a pretty formidable front row
not very attractive
but just terrific guys as well
that's cool and so what about why the
move to Scotland what what brought that
one about uh
1999 2009 I was sort of sitting on the
bench a little bit in in 2000
um and I sort of looked at him well I'm
27 26 27
um and I looked at going over to Bath
tomorrow really yeah there was there was
I I got offered a contract to get a bath
I actually got together the Warriors if
I wanted to go never go correctly and
then I thought well why don't we have to
tackle
what position did they see as a winner
oh yeah was Mark Ellis still there at
the time
he put the good word in for you yeah
yeah well he was he was you know he
tuned up being ended up being a double
International yeah mate that's pretty
impressive but I just I I love watching
the game yeah I just never thought I'd
be good at the game so and I still had a
few things I wanted to do rugby voice
yeah I just love rugby so have you
played any League no no no no that's
cool yeah around at last time but um but
uh and technically wasn't all unless the
things we wanted to do all this so
um I thought no bug at that yeah and uh
so yeah rugby was in in the opportunity
to go go overseas was
um the chance to go and have a look
around yeah and uh but I went checked
out bath first
um and just didn't quite work out and
then an offer came to go to England and
I hit a Scottish grandparent so I had
what they called a you know grandparents
entrance certificate so it got me the
chance to go and work there without him
to her worry about passports and all
this sort of stuff so Edinburgh was and
um and where we went with no intentions
or thought process of playing for
Scotland really no I just was going to
play for Edinburgh
preconceived sort of ideas around what
was you know that could happen no
conversation no no conversations nothing
like that
um and it was just a it was just a you
know because I had my scholarship
Heritage and yeah and uh where I went so
um yeah it was uh it was a bizarre
couple of first weeks yeah it all
happened really quick didn't it root
problem if uh horn saw it probably too
fast yeah
um so my wife and I got off the plane
um we got taken to our
um flat
walked in we you know dropped off by
three o'clock in the morning we're
sitting up a bed going so yeah the old
wrong uh you know timelines yeah time
clocks all that yeah so we were sitting
here going geez you know what are we
doing here and then uh and then the next
day I gotta I went away to do um
physical so you know um went to a doctor
did all that and while I was driving
back with the head coach of Edinburgh
the Scotland teams rang up and they want
you in the into the Scotland a team
I knew the All Blacks were there they're
on tour yeah and uh and I knew they were
playing Scotland a because I was Keen to
go and have a watch yeah because I knew
the guys I was trying to get tickets
and uh so they were playing in a place
called person
you're going to play for Scotland hey in
full week and I was like
okay right I'll give that a crack so I
went away to training I said to my wife
I said I look I'm not too sure and I'll
be back I presume I'll be back after the
game on on Tuesday yeah so it's a
Tuesday night up in in Perth about 40
minutes out of Indra so I went and uh
played against all black stood there you
know watched the new blacks do the
hacker I knew all the guys
Paul Miller was standing directly in
front of me he'd help me shift the house
um Simon mainly is in front of him you
know look it was it was a bizarre
feeling and of course I was sort of
joking around to weave it yeah not not I
wasn't taking it serious but I just
couldn't believe I was standing you know
I knew those those 22 guys but I didn't
know those 21 standing beside me you
know I got room with a guy a guy Ellen
Jacobson and chunky he ended up playing
about 100 games for for around Scotland
yeah he was from a place called Preston
Pence for three days I remember that guy
I do not know what the hell he said
because I've got a different dialect and
I'd just modern them and go yep because
it's gold and try and sneak out type
thing and and wanted to about three or
four years later when I was just about
to leave Scotland he goes you know I
thought you either you're rude is broken
the world I said what is it he goes mate
for three days those first few days he
never spoke to me I said man I didn't
know what the hell you were saying oh
you're not being a great mate with this
but I honestly didn't have a clue
because he had that thick really
thickness and he was coming out with me
so I'd have never heard my life yeah so
uh I must admit the first three days of
school very bizarre and then furnace the
game
got a uh got a um ear tap on the
shoulder and and they said um or we want
you going to the Scotland Camp all right
did you play well you must have oh yeah
not too bad I didn't really sit the
world alive or anything but
um
I'd played 60 minutes and they took me
off fuel um and I was like oh that's
cool and um you know I was jumping out
of the shower and
um Dougie Morgan who was the who was the
manager of the team come and tipped me
on the show and said uh grab your bag
and and um you come and come with us so
our way I went on the Wednesday that was
Wednesday I went to training
um Thursday was my wedding anniversary
there's any chance I might be a sneak
home and just having my window I said my
wife doesn't even know where I am yeah
so um he was really nice and let me go
home
and we're back to a flat and um see the
wife I said look I'm not too sure when
I'll be there and the poor girl was like
oh she was wondering what the hell we're
doing here and of course the worst part
was when they named me all the Press
came out and said whoa I forgot this
kiwi tuning up and why has he gone
straight in the team and which was
totally fair enough because I'd only
been here four days you're writing it
you agreeing
this is fantastic but then when it sort
of came out in the paper and everything
and like I said but at hindsight it was
it probably wasn't handled that well but
I was never going to say no I remember
ringing my dad going might have put me
for the Scotland team anyway we'll get
into it yeah it was all real okay so
that was more been telling I was going
to go out and enjoy it and
I think I'm about the only guy that's
played the All Blacks twice in a week
that's a stat you know like and so here
I am again standing in front of the All
Blacks and and they're doing the hacker
and once again I knew these 22 guys but
I didn't know these guys
um so crazy yeah and I'm standing
looking in his Jonah and and tunnel
there wasn't any winking or joking in
ORS
those fingers was a bit tight it was
sweet and big time so
um it was a it was a different killer
fish that's for sure yeah so did you
feel all that pressure from
um everywhere else all the media and
stuff did you feel yeah even when you're
playing in that game you probably did a
bit Yeah well I knew I had to perform
because and and the guy that dropped or
drops not great they just put me in and
he he you know tried I don't like the
weird job because he was he was
outstanding because he'd got played the
play of the day the week before oh yeah
against
um Tonga
and so they dropped him I was like man
that makes sense for anyway I was going
to question it too much there's a guy
Derek Lee ended up being in the inbra
team yeah great guy so I ended up
getting alongside him and and took him
for a beer and said hey look mate we're
going to be teammates I said this was
not my decision type thing and it wasn't
handled right yeah he ended up being
bloody great about it but it was a it
was uh I knew there was pressure yeah
and there was pressure just putting the
Scotland Jersey on anyway it was test
match rugby I I
I didn't think I'd even get there you
know a small guy from temuka
playing test rugby
um and playing
you know the all racks um wow it was it
was pretty full-on and you know one
experience but I knew I had to pull my
finger out like once again I think we
are coming with final scores about 45 12
or something like that but I remember
before the game just the the Scottish
boys were sort of you know getting into
it and warming up and stuff and I was
sitting again what this is crazy
what was the anthems like did you did
you get stuck into flower and that's
it's funny to see that because we had
the we had a press conference the day
before and they picked us and and they
named the team and I'm at fullback and
went into the press conference
and the guy says oh do you one of the
Scottish reporters goes oh do you even
know this Flower of Scotland and I
put back a bit and I said well do you
know the national anthem in New Zealand
because now I said well like I've only
been here so
um I managed to tap the foot along I did
try and learn the words
but it was a it was a pretty in
murrayfield you know 68 000 people a
year yeah
um the singer was awesome and and uh it
was a pretty proud moment I must admit I
I was very
yeah I'll go back to my my grandmother
my mom what was all my mum side of the
family
um and I I went and and made a big
effort to to follow my Heritage through
and and you know I was very proud to
play for Scotland it was a pretty cool
pretty cool moment yeah who did you lock
eyes with in the haka well I was looking
at Jonah but it wasn't the smartest
movement so I tried to fight engine
mutants
I've seen the moots out for the game I
said you're away at the vacuum yep it's
a crazy man yeah no I must admit it was
uh it was one of those ones where
there's a real
uh aura that comes off the All Blacks
anyway especially when they're standing
there in their black black uniform but
to stand there in front of them when
they're doing the hacker it's um you
know let's see the first first time
around
um I guess Scotland a was a bit
different this one was too much rugby
and it was like
these powerful stuff and uh yeah I must
admit there wasn't a lot of uh I wasn't
trying to look at too many people know
why because uh Jonah was like the eyes
were bulging
so I tried to stay away from him as best
I could did you get did you end up being
one-on-one with them at any point uh I
had a couple of times I got him
um and it was when I say Gollum was I
got his ink one yeah that's right yeah
yeah
um I tried to stay away from him as much
as I could they were they were we
actually hanging the game quite well but
it was the last sort of 25-30 minutes
where they sort of pulled away but um or
Mark trying to quite a few different
times yeah
um I mean he was just a freak yeah and
he had such a big gate on him you go to
tackle both leagues but you could only
get one yeah yeah
sometimes
[Laughter]
all right that's that's a crazy story
did it get it any easier for you
um playing for Scotland or did the
pressure come off yeah when did you feel
like that came off
um I
I don't think it ever really did I think
that that kiwi yeah you are children can
we take yeah
um Hospital remember speaking to Glenn
Metcalfe about it um and and Marty
Leslie was the same
um in in tour of JL John moosey as well
you know that that they expected you to
perform all the time and and that's fair
enough you know we were playing for
adopted country
and um and they expect the big things
and not only for Scotland was also for
your Club side as well you know so
that's that was cool I I didn't want
that too much but um but the the media
over there pretty brutal they don't they
don't muck around yeah
um and uh you know there was there was
some pretty full-on articles written
yeah and um I remember going home there
not long after all this you know a
couple of months in my wife said [__]
what have we done have we made the right
decision here it was I even questioned
it sometimes I was like Christmas yeah
should have gone to the Warriors which
should have gone to the Warriors at
least one Mr tickle no you know he
wouldn't have made it too much but these
were they were the the Press over there
pretty brutal so
um it took them a while they calmed down
a little bit but um
it always got brought up yeah you know
it was always our brilliant and Brendan
Lane he got pulled into the you know
team yeah after being there for five
days one more Choice mate yeah so I just
thought only way I could make that
change was by doing what I could control
and it was going out and plan and and
get involved with the people where I
enjoyed that part that was a bit I
really enjoyed was was meeting the
Scottish people they're awesome yeah
just great people and I had a lot of fun
doing that part you would have been glad
there's no social media
probably most of my Rugby Creator issue
man yeah yeah I'm so glad there wasn't
any of that around
it would have been dangerous yeah so all
this media back then all this negative
media you're getting the newspaper
absolutely the news yeah absolutely yeah
in in rugby was a special in Scottish
newspapers was about four pages in oh
yeah you know football was so big over
there but anything that was in
a very negative and it was and that
wasn't just for me it was for Roby
engine yeah
um and in in Edinburgh my first year we
didn't want to I must admit we we
struggled um was it till the second and
third year because I was lucky I had
Tony black out of there oh yeah how was
that how was it really great yeah Tony
is a bloody legend Champion man um not
very good at directions
um I wouldn't give him a map
um maybe he had a car and all of this
thing and this is no [__] he had a
car given to him because he was an all
black Captain and uh I had to get a bus
with my wife to his place so we could
take him in his car because he was too
chicken to go and drive anywhere so we
sat in the car my wife was I was driving
a wash on the um on the map none of this
none of this stuff yeah and he's sitting
in the front seat like we were going
where are we going so um I'll never
forget that blackhead is the shittest
when it comes to directions
okay
um I can confirm that that is good stuff
but I was lucky that he was here the
other guy that was fantastic everything
was made it easily oh yeah and Marty had
been there for um about three four years
before me anyway but um and he was real
established and but just a bloody
Champion man and uh he he was he was
good fun yeah really good and he was
great for us too because and my wife
because he got involved and and he
showed us around and he was just just a
genuine good guy how did your wife find
living in Edinburgh in the end yeah
loved it he absolutely loved it got
involved with
um a bit of work
um started running a nightclub and uh at
the membership sort of things in there I
called the opal Lounge right in the
middle of town you got back behind the
bar not behind it in front of what a
good fun of her not caught out a couple
of times too don't worry yeah yeah go on
oh I hit him one night one night I got
called out bad she had gone back to New
Zealand for uh for a wedding yeah it's
winning and I couldn't go because we
were playing rugby
you've been away five weeks and uh so I
knew I had one night left before she
came home the next day and I had to pick
her up at like have a state in the
morning
and we played an island that night and
we got back about 11 o'clock and then I
thought I'd better go to the open Lounge
yeah and duck in so I'd had a few but
the open Lounge was done it was
downstairs
my pockets and I tripped on about the
second steer up now face into the stairs
and when I went down I was like [__] I
tuned my head and I cut myself open and
the bounce boys come down and put me up
and they were laughing away it was
hilarious
and they took me to the top I knew them
because they knew Miranda yeah you were
there everywhere yeah
man because it's cold I woke up in the
morning a big black eye and a cup and
everything
and uh so anyway pick up the water and I
hadn't seen him for five weeks hey
sweetheart hell yeah it's because
I bugging off the training on the Monday
you know God she would work yeah and I
got a text and she went you're a lying
bastard I was like oh what am I looking
at she because I've just seen the CCTV
Carriage of you crashing into the into
the stairs I was like [__] so I didn't
live that one here so every time every
time from then on every time I got to
the top of the stairs of your business
are you right you mate you want me to
give you a hand down you know like
oh that'd be good footage
called out big time though I've tried to
delete it
oh it's good stuff so you you obviously
loved your time in Edinburgh
um playing playing in Edinburgh as well
did yeah yeah I loved it yeah we were I
think the year
um 2004 we got in the
um we got in the quarterfinals of the
Heineken Cup which is this is the big
try against to lose
what a try that was yeah the two is one
I um
yeah that was it was nuts because even
even Tony come up to me afterwards
um intimate you're pulled away from
intimacy I think he was about 35 so I'm
gonna say pulling away you probably
wasn't that Keenan chasing me but um we
ended up getting in the series I caught
a finals we ended up planning to lose it
over there yeah and it was the first
time a Scottish team had gone into any
super final quarter final
so it was pretty big freedom in Scottish
rugby so it was great
um and we had we had a really good team
really good bunch of guys made lifelong
friends with with most of them they're
just good people and uh but we played a
really cool style of rugby and
the guy Frank hedden was coaching at the
time
um uh he wanted to play expensive and
throw it around man no descriptive guys
we previously probably battled without a
wee bit but um toddy brought in a few
different things that obviously the
Crusaders done I brought him a few
things that the tiger boys or hollanders
had done and it just sort of mixed well
with the guys we had we ruined a big big
front row or big locks or anything like
that
um so we had to move around a bit and we
weren't really that big in the back I
was one of the bigger backs so we used
speed to move around and Chuck it around
in in our school level and it was it was
really successful yeah when we come up
and get some of the bigger teams we're
probably better but we um you know
especially up front but yeah it was a it
was an enjoyable time because we were
playing rugby that everyone was here and
joined but we also enjoyed it off the
field as well you know they're a great
Bunch off the field so how did it all
end in Scotland for you uh well 2005 was
it was
um if I'm honest it was probably time to
go I'd
well it uh falling down a favor is
probably not the word I hadn't been
picked for for the scholars team met
Williams was in the coaching
um and I I wasn't playing my best rugby
I probably
I was moving into second five I've been
put at second five I was in the second
five's bum to be honest I wasn't
enjoying it yeah
um I was playing that at Edinburgh
because there was no one else needed to
do it at the time
um I enjoyed it it didn't remember
because I had a bit more freedom but I
was in the second floor of a test level
why I got found out in a couple of games
um and I I really shouldn't have been
planning I probably should put my hand
up and said hey look I'm I'm a full week
I was 31 yeah um it's going on 32 I'd
I'd if I'm honest I was getting you
tired of the of the everyday grind going
to rugby training especially over there
today in the winters it's freezing three
o'clock
and you know like I was looking over it
yeah and it was time for a change and
originally I was going to come back to
New Zealand um I was I always said
before I leave because I ended up
playing about 80 odd games for for a
table I thought oh I'll be cool to get
100 yeah
and also many guys were going over
they'd stay overseas from the time yeah
not a lot of them were coming back and
having another Creek yeah and and I
thought well if it wasn't a takeout nice
to go and play Maybe 50 games to see a
canary or something
um but then uh Leon McDonald
um he was at Yamaha and and he decided
he'd be me for I think a year and um he
was having troubles with this we fellow
you know going to school and yeah and
it's pretty tough for for kids over in
Japan so he decided to leave and and the
opportunity just popped up and I was
leaving Scotland and yeah sure worked
out yeah it just all sort of worked out
um so we ended up going to Yamaha uh
Motor Company and and playing for a
couple of Seasons sorry two years there
two years yeah yeah I probably could
have had another one
um uh my wife fell pregnant so um it was
time to come home we wanted always
wanted that with your face yeah there
was the first one yeah
um
and it was just it was just torn yeah
you know I'd sort of
uh not given up a rugby Ambitions yeah
but it was just
the juices were getting too tight for a
start to me so I want to get rid of that
one um but it was I just had enough and
I wanted to try I was sort of moving on
to the next part of my life and and um
nice famous kids and doing things so
yeah did you have plans there for that
next part of your life not really yeah
no not really I um I struggled the start
I didn't know what I was going to do I
had to come and look at a couple of
different things
um maybe looking at one of the our
houses
um but that never really worked out
um and then I had done a bit of work
while I was in Dunedin for um for a
company
um here in town you see in Christchurch
called JW Sport and they were selling
sports uniforms yeah corporate uniforms
and that so I did a little bit of work
while I was playing rugby professionally
and it was more just put people in
contact with you know hey you need some
hoodies or whatever yeah so I did that
outside of rugby because I couldn't do
rugby all the time yeah I need something
else and I knew that if you know one
injury and I was gone so I had to go and
do something uh just a little bit
different so that opportunity came up so
it was uh it was a business here in town
JW sport he was wanting to retire
um and um and he offered me the chance
to buy the business so um I bought into
that and uh and came back to
Christchurch so um with not really
knowing what I was doing but how how far
was this post footy how long pretty much
straight up well yeah 2007 came back
pretty much got off the plane on a
Saturday started work on Monday and uh
he was a bit scariest you know in in
hindsight's a great thing obviously but
you know I wish I'd probably
um learned a bit more or
um you know business it's all well and
good owning a business but there's a
whole lot of stuff that goes with it
that I knew nothing about so you've
obviously learned on the run because
obviously very successful now you've
want to explain what how you've got to
we are now with impex yeah it was taking
a while doing here
um so I had Joe dub sport for a while
and then um the opportunity to merge
into
um and I I wanted to get a hold of the
monogramming part of it because that was
the big part of what we did yeah so we
you know embellished all the gear that
we did yeah so it was a chance to to do
that or actually started off the company
called snomey Sports
yeah Andrew was uh I'm meeting him up in
Hong Kong just to just a champion men
and uh but then he his wife got a job up
in taranaki yeah
um so he was coming over and he said
Allah I'm going to take their part over
I said totally understand so we we
finished up Emma could be a real good
man and I I had to do something I I had
all these clients so I started up and
picked
um with Chris England
um but Scotty played uh over 100 games
for Canterbury
um and uh played smart man we didn't
play for the Holiness for a year and uh
and so we we were working together and
uh and so we started up and picked Peril
and it was really to cover if the time
um all the tsunami um customers that I
had and uh so we've sort of built that
up over a period of time it's been about
four years now and yeah and now we're
starting to do pads and you know put
other stuff as well so it's very massive
now yeah well we're trying to mate it's
like anything
um you know we're learning as regardless
yeah
um but it's also uh we're not just rugby
we've tried to get into other areas yeah
you know we've we've made mistakes since
we've gone as is one does we try to
minimize those as much as we can but um
we've got some pretty cool pretty cool
stuff to to offer and and what myself
and Chris have both come from
backgrounds of of Club you know Club
Rugby's it's bloody tough for clubs at
the moment no struggling money was
they're struggling with with numbers
and they want to make it easy so when
they do get on the field it's it's a
One-Stop shop so yeah trying to achieve
yeah that's cool and we do see it in
sort of five ten years what's what's the
big plans for it on well we're at the
moment we've luckily enough we've got a
really good guy in Dunedin he's doing a
bit of stuff for us down there coot and
then uh I've got um you know a young
fella up in palmy North uh Matt who's um
been bloody good yeah so loved him and
uh and we'd like to maybe put someone up
in maybe Wellington and then and then up
in Auckland and try and cover the New
Zealand anyway yeah um and so look we
could try and aim for the stars and and
try and get you know all the big
promises that there would be great but
um you know we're small steps and we're
just trying to make sure that we're you
know looking after the the clubs really
well and and doing that that part right
because uh it's it's pretty tough here
doing a bloody good job and how did the
sky commentary come here yeah come in
and was that always something yeah no it
wasn't SUV I beat Mel Robinson over at
um Hong Kong
um Stevens oh yeah yeah and uh she was
in the same Hotel got I just got janitor
at the bar early one night and um she
knew I made a morning
um really well so we just got chatting
and and she said oh you should you
should give the containing a crack I
said well never even thought about it
yeah and I and I didn't think about it
anymore in about three or four months
later I got a phone call from um from
Sky saying do you want to come and give
it a go so I remember going and standing
behind um uh Johnny Preston it was
actually me and Razer and we stood
behind uh it was Razer learning to do it
as well he had a crack as well he
obviously picked a bit apart
and I'll win their way
so uh yeah we're still behind them
watched um what's JP who's a who was an
expert yeah and um and then got got the
chance to really got chucked to Mike in
a in a program and she'd go for it so um
she was a lot of loon in the names
pretty quick yeah I still can't get any
more but it's it's cool fun that's kept
me in the in the rugby mix yeah which I
really love I love that that Community
part and um you know I've met some
bloody cool people so it's been really
good what were your nerves like before
yeah
I think I read the program about a
hundred times
it was uh yeah put it this way luckily
it wasn't summer playing because uh
trying to get some of those names out
was really tough but I'm sure some of
the guys parents hated them when they
named them because some of the names you
go God or Morty it's bloody tough but um
and you want to do that right yeah you
don't want to muck it up for the guys
because you know as I suppose it was
like me when you watch cf1 TV but yeah
you know getting the getting the guys
names wrong it's not cool so um but
there's there's tougher when you know
when you've got to do it in a hurry yeah
you know do they do they coach you on
that like I've always wondered that do
the commentators get coaching on how to
pronounce I Look to be feared it's got
better yeah
have a go hypocrite in in we're probably
lucky because there was something
outstanding you know Grant Elizabeth
golden tonsils one of the best yeah Ken
Laban was a champ or is a champ yeah and
he helped me out a heap uh Woolly Lucy
yeah he was outstanding as well um so we
had guys around that were had been done
in a while and they were really great
help but um there was a lot of just
getting there and have a crack which I
can't enjoyed yeah and how's it work for
you now did you just make yourself
available for whatever yeah just
available never yeah pretty pretty
relaxed through fear look I'm I'm
probably away with the other way Jimmy
I'm going out the other end you know
there's courses are coming off playing
um overseas now playing in the game at
that level yeah
um you know the games definitely changed
not not necessarily rules but certainly
the way that the teams approach it
nothing there's some younger guys now
coming through who you know they're
finishing up retiring have uh you know
gives you digs of this world yeah you
know they've been in in that sort of
environment for a while and I'm probably
heading out the other end so
um I've had a great 10 12 years doing it
it's been bloody growth I know I lost
the hanging in there I'm off to the West
Coast next week
and uh and I enjoy it I enjoy it
there's some just some cool people
around
um the rugby environment and it keeps me
in touch did you ever have any ambition
to get behind that call the game from up
top I I always wanted to give the
correct one though but I just don't know
whether it's a hell of a hell of a skill
that yes it really is
um and you'd probably have to ease your
way into it and uh oh yeah I've been
lucky I've I've been I've set up saw the
best you watch Grant to it yeah and
lisbo was just you know the me and the
time and effort that goes into the
preparation and yeah it's a big job it
really is man they've put they put a lot
of time and effort and that's outside of
what they're doing normally too you know
um and we we even just guys didn't slide
on we've got to put a bit of working too
and yeah and know your players but that
that commentator
yeah and it's and it happens fast yeah
you know it comes out real fast so
you've got to get it right so yeah I
would have liked to go but I think that
that one more possible I think it has oh
mate maybe at West Coast this weekend
I think I'm going with Donnie Bell I'm
just hoping Donnie doesn't blow up on me
and I'll be sweet
well mate as always we do on this um
podcast we go to our questions from the
Instagram and
um a popular man like yourself it's
coming with plenty first one is tell the
story of when you crashed your car
oh I'll probably keep the other one to
myself
just for drawing driving Tony's car was
it yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
no I yeah yeah that was embarrassing man
I didn't hit it that long either that
was the worst part well how were you
just what 16. yeah yeah it was just dumb
yeah
[Laughter]
okay next one hardest player to tackle
Jonah easily yeah yeah without the doubt
um and um and to be fair the next one
was Damien Carey
but uh you know Jonah was just so tough
and
saying to me yeah you've got to take his
space away you know get up there fast to
take a space for us mate
try and Tackle him
and he can run them down 11 second 100
meters you know yeah I'm sitting here
scutting them behind them so um yeah no
Jonah was he was tough was real tough as
well yeah you know tunnel was just so
strong and and a good step too yeah yeah
that's right yeah in in Finnish you know
that whole bloody hurricanes backlog
Kelly as well
um once again I think I need bloody
Shuckers in a few times afterwards but
you know they were outstanding yeah and
that's where the you know going back
some of those all black boys they were
they had an awesome awesome mix right
yeah some Talent there right oh some
Legends okay best player you played with
yeah Goldie were different yeah purely
just purely because of a skill level and
he read the game so well we could he had
the ball on a string sometimes you know
you saw you saw him in South Africa in
97 where he he chased caught it scored
you know that stuff to do it at that
pace and Kelly was another guy yeah if I
didn't play with Kelly but played
against him plenty of times and and he
was a freak yeah he absolute freak
wasn't big
strong as an ox I think the one part of
it is probably one of the best bench
presses yeah
um but he was just fast and he could
change direction and quick yeah
um that was really hard to defend yeah
and um
you know to have a guy on what that in
your team was pretty pretty special some
special players okay next one best court
session you're involved in you would
have been involved then plenty of good
ones
and and we had Mark Ellis he came up it
was
96. yeah and uh we're up and up in
Wellington up in Auckland sorry and the
Warriors have played that night
I wasn't worried that might have been
there is it might not have been might
have been the kiwis had played oh yeah
because Johnny Timmy was here as well
Charlie Timmy one of the best you ever
meet absolute Legion so they came to the
court session and we'd had a we'd had
plenty I think we played we had to play
both Harbor of Auckland come here or we
lost
so we're here into the court session and
we ripped into it but every time Mecca
came up with
every time you buffed your your stubby
yeah you had to get up and play it
[Music]
fossils everywhere around the room and
smashed and it was just like everyone's
shot I remember walking outside and
Johnny to me was in the garden and that
was at the end of the court session so
you can tell you there how that how well
that went
um I woke up in the morning with this
with
um with uh made of one that uh from
cockroach he'd come up the watch yeah
and he was in Auckland for someone and I
woke up in the morning and we had the
awning bought out and it was and
Smithereens we were trying to Surf
why we were trying to do that I don't
know Jimmy but um I distinctly remember
breaking it so and I don't think I paid
for it
yeah we probably shouldn't have hit as
many as we did but we you knew you had a
good one when you got into the third
kick yeah and that was going good
a few times what about Mark Alex you
mentioned there what was what was he
like as a as a character
hilarious yeah yeah he was just so sharp
yeah and I mean I mean we came back
after he did his league and he played
um and uh I mean he he came back and he
ended up playing football I just ended
up sitting on the beach quite a bit that
year and and you know Mecca was a big
player than it was yeah but um he was uh
just around the team
um just always joking and and it was
people gravitated to him yeah but he was
also it wasn't just him he would you
know he'd talk to everyone and he just
had a knack of having everyone in
stitches and it was just he was just a
cracking dude and and great to be um in
his team as well because he could play
some footage too yeah yeah real good but
um afterwards was the best part
you and him yeah
okay next question did you really say
Mark that when commentating or did you
actually say [__] up what did say
mucked up was it honest to God or put my
hand up there it did sound like it
because I'd gone when it happened
felt pretty shitty about it afterwards
but when it happened was this a
Schoolboy game yeah it was it was
Christchurch it was
um the same I think it was cross oh yeah
anyway the kid from Cross was kicked to
the corner and it went dead oh yeah in
um uh the god of contenting with he put
his microphone down and was was writing
something down yeah and and of course I
was I oh [__] I better say something
yeah and I went oh I know he's really
mucked it up but I hit my microphone
quite a lot because when you when you
got your commentator Mike you mean to
have it up here yeah yeah and I heard it
sitting out here
so
um it didn't really probably sound the
clearest
and um I should have said he [__] up
and so
um I I of course I said it and then I
heard him yeah because you got the
producers and everything out in the
truck and everything and I heard them
going oh and I thought they were talking
about the kick so you know game finished
I left I went down to a mailman's wife
passed away unfortunately and I went to
to
um the funeral and it was down in Wanaka
yeah and I ended up at Lake hawia and
there was no coverage where we were so I
had two days down there
no coverage
having a few beers down there and then
we fought him a wife and I got in the
car to head back to Christchurch
and my phone started gun nuts and it was
like ring sky sport
and then I looked at stuff and here I am
with a big picture of me going on about
me swearing
[Laughter]
holy [__] and it really kicked off I was
like so I was oh [__] [__] [__] sorry I
ring sky in the in the media lady was
great she said oh look we've gone
through the coverage again and and
it sounds like it but we know you
haven't seen it and I said well honestly
I'll put my hand if I'd see that I would
have just yeah yeah and say look off
so I said look one guy that's got to be
spraying towards the kid yeah so I rang
the school
I've got a hold of the manager of the
team and I said oh look mate I'm really
sorry but have you got this guys and I I
want to talk to him
and it's really bad I can't remember his
name but it was a hell of a nice kid on
the phone so I rang him up and I said
hey look buddy it's Brilliant Lane here
I'm yeah I've got to apologize I didn't
say it but it's certainly come out like
that and I said look I've cleaning those
dead mates so I said you know and the
rest of you you played fantastically
well so I was backing you all the way
but I said I apologize if it's come
across that way and he said oh no no
that's all right mate we all had a laugh
about it in the in the in the um preview
and I said oh that's right and he said
um Andy before he said I did [__] it up
and I was like mate what a champ yeah a
great kid but look it was it was just
yeah it came out and it certainly
sounded like it but I definitely didn't
do it I'd put my hand in there yeah yeah
and get on you for giving him a call
because it wasn't for you on the Freer
on the guy yeah and uh and he played
well too there was just one thing that
just didn't go quite right so oh good
stuff okay next one favorite memory in
the Scotland Jersey uh
there was one game we played against
South Africa in 2004 and um and they
were number two in the world at the time
two or three and we were sitting about
eighth and uh we played them in our
Autumn test which was November
um it was my birthday it was 16th of
November we ran out and um
I was playing 12 that day I loved
playing yeah
but I was goal kicking oh yeah so um and
we ended up beating them we ended up
beating them like I remember Corner
clicker was was the captain and we I
held him up over the line one part of it
and he got up and give me a clip around
the year and we had a bit of a push and
shove it was like man you're a [__]
he called me a decade and then we went
down to the other end of the field and I
had a shot at gold right in front half
time if as soon as I kicked it was half
time yeah and I missed it and he ran
straight past me and gave me a mouthful
you know useless proactive fat and all
this sort of crap so anyway second half
we ended up beating them and I ran
straight past corner and I said what'd
you say yeah
[Laughter]
it was just a great day out and and uh
um in in no disrespect but no no one was
expecting us to break safe yeah and I
think some of the guys in the team
weren't expecting us to win that game
but we just you know in a game it just
reflects yeah you know we trained it
week and was and it was
it's quite funny it's it's it's a
different thing when we played England
the attitude to an English Six Nations
game or an England game was totally
different to playing at uh South Africa
on All Blacks
the English game was just something
about it the guys in the Scotland team
flick a different switch whereas they'd
of course be careful outside we probably
weren't
expecting to go out and beat the All
Blacks but mate they were going to go
out there and kill them and it was a
totally different different killer
fresheners yeah it really was it was
quite it was quite strange I found it
quite strange but I can understand the
history yeah yeah but the surfing game
we just everything you know it's just
collecting one of those games chasing
you down yeah
the sort of goes on to the next question
who do you think's gonna win the Rugby
World Cup
well look I suppose at the moment if
you're a bidding man
um France at home is going to be really
tough to beat
um South Africa are going to be tough to
beat
um Ireland been number one in the world
at the moment yeah they'll be extremely
tough to beat over there and the way
they're performed in the couple of
warm-up games have been bloody hard hard
to um hard they'll be hard to beat
um
I really like the way the All Blacks are
tracking at the moment
um just the way that they've performed
it particularly when you know the old s
has been on them yeah it really is
um all those four teams are on one side
of the pole it's crazy it really is
um and and that's one thing that worries
me a little bit is airport build up you
know we've got French first up and then
a hell of a quarterfinal that's right so
we yeah we're gonna have to
really perform and hope you know injury
wise that you know we get through and I
just like the way the guys have gone out
there and performed because geez I've
played some good rugby
um and everyone's been on them and
you know to be fear the fuzzy yeast got
a bit of pressure on them too yeah
um so I think they've handled that
really really well but look
even if they went out and played South
Africa in this last one and lose yeah no
one will give a [__] if they get to the
end of it and and want it so I just hope
that they they
um they go out there and perform really
well but I I think we're good enough to
do it
Ireland and France are going to be tough
to bring that first game is going to be
an absolute Beauty again the absolute
Ripper I suppose we even meet some
Aussie yeah you know they could be a
um they could be one of those games that
could tip someone up Scotland Scotland
Scotland and that that one here in
particular the tournaments is going to
be huge from the South Africa match is
going to be huge for them that'll be a
really interesting pool yeah I love to
see the Scottish boys get up because gee
they're playing some good ones oh it's
been really awesome to watch
um in in from a Scottish point of view
um a Terry Scotsman like yourself
they've been bloody brilliant absolutely
who do you support when Scotland play
the All Blacks oh I'm Scottish
it was I was a real honor to play 20
tests for them in um in yeah yeah
absolutely yeah okay next one best otago
after party
98 98 was a was a ripper we we won the
NPC in 98 and then we ended up
um back at the guardies Sports Tavern
yeah I remember walking in
and we actually couldn't get in we had I
had the um the big NPC trophy yeah the
big one it fits about four jokes
I remember walking into the garden he's
put our head in front of me like that
yeah and things really got taken off me
and I was like oh [__] it's gone but we
actually physically couldn't get in
there it was chocolate I've never seen
anything like it yeah any other time
it's been chocolate was National nude
day but it was it was yeah yeah and it
got taken behind the bar and filled
obviously we finally got in there that
whole place was absolutely humpy but it
wasn't just in it it was outside there's
people on the streets
and and that that was one of the bigger
ones I must admit they went for about
three days and we had to be at the
boardroom I mean we had to be at the
boardroom for like your mid Monday which
ended up being the Sunday yeah you had
to be there at
um 10 o'clock if you went there uh
leaving the clock sorry if you weren't
there by 11 o'clock it was a jug every
minute you were late
and it was about three boys that smucked
in a bit late and I'll tell you what
they that
the most impressive part and I came here
was that yeah I'm pretty sure it was but
Calvin Middleton
yeah and I wouldn't call him a massive
drinker but I'll tell you what he must
have smoked seven or eight jugs that day
and never missed a beat it was real
impressive really I don't think he's
ever done it ever again seven minutes
late
absolutely unbelievable I've never seen
her before my life but it was impressive
very impressive oh times have definitely
changed
okay last question best piece of advice
you had for a woodland listener
oh look if it's purely just around rugby
I'm just gonna go out there enjoy it
um spicy species young fellas um I think
there's a lot of pressure on the young
guys in in professional environment but
you've first and foremost it's a game to
enjoy and yeah that's why I love playing
it it was it was just great fun I loved
the guys in it love the people around it
anything today I suppose like anything
if an environment is good and you're
enjoy it you're playing peace rugby
um uh the other one is lost short mate
that goes pretty bloody quick
um I'm 50 years old this year and
it feels like yesterday it was running
around on a rugby field but I can tell
you now
um you get up in the morning yeah
make a few different noises you've been
over to throw your shoes up and make a
few different noises and uh and now I've
got kids in it you get a bit of an
Terminator again what's in the in-play
sport but I tell you what it goes like
that yeah and uh and you you really got
to go out there and give everyone a
crack that's what I think and um you
know certainly I've done I've done my
fuse here mate you definitely have and
going through this um podcast you just
realize how much you've actually done
and yeah yes but like that yeah it's
been a bit bizarre really it's not
something you don't sit down and reflect
no you don't
um you usually just copy the ship from
the banks but it's um it's been pretty
cool yeah pleasure to have you on my
true true legend of the game and I'm
hearing your story and some of that um I
mean your Scotland debut definitely
stands out as playing all works twice in
a week and your first week over there
it's one of those moments where you're
just like honestly I never ever thought
I'd ever sit there and say that yeah and
uh and it was bizarre yeah it really
bizarre but like you know something I
can tell my grandkids about one day
maybe if I get there that long if I keep
on making noise
you have it you're a true legend true
lead and really appreciate you giving up
your time and coming out awesome thanks
very much